die Deutsche Bahn AG gehört zu 100% im
Staat ist mit über 200.000 Mitarbeitern
einer der größten Arbeitgeber
Deutschlands und beförderte allein
letztes Jahr 132 Millionen Menschen im
Fernverkehr mit einer sagenhaften
Pünktlichkeit von
65%
zu spät war also jeder dritte Zug doch
wie konnte so weit kommen 1994 das Jahr
der Bahnreform Pünktlichkeitsquote heute
unvorstellbare 90% doch dann soll die
Bahn an die Börse und was viele nicht
wissen Börse das ist ein anderes Wort
für kaputt sparen denn jetzt kommt alles
unentable einfach weg 1994 hatte die
Deutsche Bahn ein Betriebsnetz von mehr
als 41 000 km Länge heute sind es nur
noch rund 33.000 und da wir seitdem auch
die Hälfte aller weichen abgebaut haben
konnten wir das deutsche Weltkulturerbe
Stau auf die Schiene übertragen